now as masks become our new normal again
for the time being
health experts say wearing them can have
a big impact on whether or not we see
more variants
arco mana joins us now live to explain
well denise doctors tell me wearing a
mask is improv
is very important right now perhaps more
than
ever before they say it helps prevent
more mutations of covid19 and those
mutations
can cause some major problems by wearing
masks we're going to prevent
transmission of virus between people
masks are back in clark county amid a
rise in covet cases
dr mark j khan tells me the more time a
virus spends in a population the more
mutations like the highly transmissible
delta variant
are likely to arise but masks even for
fully vaccinated people can help
in order to get to the point where
this virus is not as rampant in our
community
we have to decrease the amount of virus
around and that's going to require
all of us wearing mass but if not
everyone follows the mask mandate and if
more people do not get vaccinated dr
khan is concerned about how effective
our current vaccines will be
we worry that we could get mutations
that are resistant to vaccine
so how long until that point dr manus
mandel tells me some research suggests
it could be relatively soon
there is a calculation that shows that
at the current rate
perhaps it's three to six months but
there's some promising news
pfizer and moderna are already talking
about
conducting clinical researches coming up
with a variant specific
vaccine formulation but to avoid this
situation
altogether includes two simple steps
it's critically
important where the mass get vaccinated
to help others
again the new mass requirement includes
everyone whether you're vaccinated or
not
while indoors in public spaces reporting
live in las vegas tonight
orcomanna 8 news now